-We have exactly
seven shows left
before we go on Christmas break,
which means it's time for
that beloved
"Tonight Show" tradition.
It is time for "12 Days of
Christmas Sweaters."
Here we go.
-♪ "12 Days of
Christmas Sweaters ♪
♪ Seven days left ♪
-That's right.
Every show between
now and Christmas,
we'll be giving
one lucky audience member
a magnificent Christmas sweater
from the
Countdown to Christmas Cabinet.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Since there are
seven shows left,
let's open door number 7.
[ Drumroll ]
Ooh! Here, right?
Go for it.
Whenever you're ready.
-Ready.
-Yeah, go.
Oh, wow!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Nice. Thank you very much.
Look at this.
Disco Santa.
Now let's see who's going home
with tonight's sweater.
Everyone look at
your seat number.
If I call your number,
come on down.
Quest, can I get
a drumroll, please?
[ Drumroll ]
Who wants a sweater?
This is a goody, this one.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Here we go!
-Here we go.
-114!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hey, come on.
Come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Hi!
Nice to meet you. How are you?
Stand right there.
-Right over here.
-What is your name
and where are you from?
-I'm Jaslene and I'm from
Norwalk, Connecticut.
-Hey! Jaslene, welcome!
Norwalk, it gets very cold
this time of year.
And you have
a beautiful sweater.
-Thank you.
-You almost can't top that.
But then you have this.
Do you have anything like
this in your wardrobe?
-No, it's unique.
-Yes, thank you.
That's a nice way of putting it.
Would you like to try it on
for everyone?
-I would.
-Oh, this is exciting.
There you go. Roots?
There you go, bud.
-Oh, we've got to do
the hands first.
-Oh, yeah,
your hands go through.
Oh, yeah. Oh, no, no, no.
I can already tell.
This is going to be gorgeous.
-I love it.
-Are you -- Come on.
Look at us. You look great.
Come on. How cute.
Yeah, give it up
for our winner right there.
Congratulations.
-Thank you!
-Guys, stick around.
We'll be right back with
Steve Martin and Martin Short.
Come on back.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪